in 2001 Danish political scientist Bjorn
Lombard burst onto the international
scene with his best-selling and
controversial book The skeptical
environmentalist the one-time member of
Greenpeace said that climate change is
real and that human activity is clearly
contributing to it but he said the best
science didn't support the apocalyptic
Visions put forth by people like Earth
and the balance author and former vice
president Al Gore lombork went on to
create the Copenhagen consensus a think
tank that applies cost-benefit analysis
to problems facing the global poor and
works with Nobel laureates policymakers
philanthropists and researchers to
develop pragmatic relatively low-cost
solutions to issues such as tuberculosis
malaria lack of education and lack of
access to food his new book is called
best things first and it presents what
Lombard says are the 12 most efficient
solutions for the world's poorest people
he argues that for about 3 35 billion
dollars a year a little more than half
of what the U.S spends annually on
humanitarian Aid these policies would
save 4.2 Million Lives and generate an
extra 1.1 trillion dollars in value
every year reason caught up with Lombard
in New York City during the latest
meeting of the United Nations General
Assembly we talked about best things
first and why politicians and the media
continue to fixate on the possibility of
future climate apocalypse rather than
helping the global poor in the Here and
Now
Bjorn lombork thanks for talking to
Reese it's great to be here thank you
let's start off by talking about your
new book best things first which is
based on the Copenhagen consensus
project that you've developed over the
past couple of decades first what is the
Copenhagen consensus
so we're really a very small think tank
that work with hundreds of the world's
top Economist to ask very simple
question
how do you get the biggest bang for your
buck look there are lots of stuff you
can do not all of it is equally good so
we simply try to sort of push for the
really smart things you can do for
whatever it is that you want to achieve
do you want to get better health care or
do you want to do something about global
warming or do you want to do good for
the world the the last the latter thing
is what this book is about it basically
asks a very simple question if you're
going to spend an extra dollar
preferably a couple hundred million
dollars or something where can you get a
lot of bang for your buck right so the
subtitle is the 12 most efficient
solutions for the world's poorest and
our Global sustainable development goals
promises uh first what are the
sustainable development goals that were
hashed out in 2015 by the United Nations
yeah so they were essentially you know
the un's attempt to try to say what
should we do for the world what should
we promise for the next 15 years from
2016 to 2030. so in 2023 three we're in
a halfway sorry we're at half time for
these promises but nowhere near halfway
so we started out saying what should we
promise and obviously you want to you
know reduce poverty or actually they
went so far to say get rid of poverty uh
we should also reduce hunger or actually
get rid of hunger oh we should also fix
War we should fix corruption we should
fix climate change we should fix
education but it ended up being
essentially an almost endless list of
promises to do all good things in the
world and make sure that people get
organic apples and know about indigenous
people and and have Community Gardens
and the whole shebang yeah it's a very
beautiful list of all the stuff that
you'd ever want if you if money was no
uh object but it is and U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez he's calling
for a 500 billion dollar kind of global
stimulus project you think that's
generally wasteful and unrealistic he's
focusing mostly on renewable energy
Universal social protection and job
creation why is that misguided well so
first of all you're not going to get
people to give half a trillion dollars
more to a project that's failing you
know so if you have a project where
you've promised everything then after
seven and a half years ago wow we didn't
make it give us more money that doesn't
really sound very reassuring but also
what you have to realize is if you're
actually going to deliver on all of the
things you promised half a trillion
dollars is not going to cut it you will
need somewhere between 10 and 15
trillion dollars to deliver all the
things we promised and of course that's
the same amount of money that all the
governments in the world are right now
raising in taxes essentially the
argument is if we want it to deliver on
everything we promised back in 2015 we'd
have to double all Global Taxes new
slash not gonna happen nobody will want
that and so you really have to go back
and say instead of spending lots and
lots of extra money which I just don't
see politically as feasible also on the
particular things that he's talking
about you know more renewable energy
nice if you're rich you can actually
afford it it feels good it makes you
feel like you're all green virtuous but
it's by no means the most effective
thing you can do for the world and so
what we're saying is look you might be
able to get a little more money let's
make sure we focus that little more
money on the very best things you can do
yeah so you're kind of the calculations
that you make in the book and it's cost
benefit analyzes which you confusingly
call Benefit cost Solutions or ratios
and things like that but is that for
about 35 billion dollars a year you say
we could save 4.2 Million Lives a year
and generate 1.1 trillion in extra value
a year and to put that in perspective
the U.S currently spends 60 billion
annually in humanitarian Aid
philanthropists and I guess in the U.S
kick in about another 30 billion so for
you know a little bit more than half of
what we the U.S government is already
spending you're saying here are 12
things that could really radically alter
it um let's talk about some of the uh
the 12 Solutions
um that you uh come up with at the top
of the list is basically ending
tuberculosis how does that happen and
why is it so cheap to add tuberculosis I
should just say it's not on the top of
the list it's just the first thing yeah
it's my turn of children I'm not going
to pick one of them so well it's all
Sophie's choices they're they're all
incredibly good choices so one of them
is tuberculosis and it's this astounding
thing that remember tuberculosis brought
on almost a tsunami of death over the
last couple hundred years if you look
back in the 1800s every fourth person
that died in the U.S and in Europe died
from tuberculosis we estimated over the
last 200 years about a bill million
people die from tuberculosis
fixed it we got antibiotics and that
basically fixed it in the rich World
nobody dies or very very few people die
from tuberculosis anymore but that's not
so in the poor part of the world every
year it still kills 1.4 million people
that makes it the most deadly infectious
disease for the last decade every year
except the two years with covet so how
do you how do you how do you address
that so again it's very simple you
simply need to get a pill while actually
you need to get a pill every day for six
months and this is one of the reasons
why it's hard you actually need to keep
taking it way after you got better and
if you've ever tried to take you know
pills for 14 days you know once once you
get fine it's sort of hard to remember
so it's actually you have to stimulate
people you have to make apps you may
have to make uh sort of efforts maybe
you have tuberculosis Anonymous where we
meet every week and say yes I took my
pills that kind of thing maybe give out
juice cartons so as premiums for making
sure people do it it sounds a little
silly but remember every person that you
can cure from tuberculosis is a person
that won't put on tuberculosis for
another 10 or 15 people for one year so
it's a very good idea the second part of
it is to test a lot of people so a lot
of people don't know that they have
tuberculosis partly because they don't
want to know it's it's a it's it has a
lot of Taboo in Kenya for instance if
you get diagnosed with tuberculosis one
in four people will lose their spouse
because they'll divorce them because you
know who wants that and and also you'll
have problems at work maybe you'll lose
your job all these kinds of things so
what you have to do is to make sure that
people recognize this is actually a very
treatable disease we've discovered it
you're getting treatment you're fine
this will cost more money but it'll also
basically save about a million people
each and every year so for about six
billion dollars we can save a million
people each and every year and that it's
related to another disease that's on the
list malaria and you know it's funny
when you talk about tuberculosis as
being a massive killer in you know
Europe and America and really until the
last century
um data malaria I mean it's amazing to
think you know that Washington DC once
and Philadelphia had massive malaria
problems in you know in American history
um how do you fix malaria we think
malaria is a tropical disease but really
that's only true because that's the only
place where we haven't gotten rid of it
remember 36 states in the U.S had
endemic malaria malaria was endemic in
Moscow and in Finland it's not a
tropical disease it's a disease of
poverty so what happens is when you get
out of poverty when you start being able
to afford I don't know put up screens in
your house so mosquitoes don't come in
you don't get malaria when you start
getting lots of uh livestock you also
get the mosquitoes to Sting the or bite
the livestock instead of you and of
course once you get rich enough you get
treatment and then you get rid of
malaria this does not happen in
sub-Saharan Africa that's almost
entirely where the problem is now so
what and and there's a number of reasons
for it they have the most deadly uh
variant of malaria they have a mosquito
that doesn't want to bite uh livestock
so they only bite people and so it's
much harder to get rid of we know how to
do it it's simply about getting many
more people to sleep under bed nets you
right are the best Nets are treated with
insects is that DDT as well no uh no
that's no longer what you use but it is
a very cheap pesticide unfortunately the
mosquitoes are now starting to become
resistant to that so they've moved to
slightly more expensive we've made our
calculations involve uh that you both
use some of the cheap ones and some of
the most expensive ones depending on
where you do it and that's what what is
reflected in the calculations
um you would talk about education
globally and there's a stat in there
which up now I I thought I had written
that it was something like 80 percent of
young people around the world can't do
basic math or reading
um so education seems to be one of those
things where everybody and you write
about this everybody you know is
constantly fixing it virtually every
country is spending more on education
than they were 20 30 40 years ago and
the results aren't better so what you
know we we went through the one laptop
per child uh fad which didn't do
anything how do you how do you address
you know Global problems with education
education is a great example of what we
try to do in general namely that
everybody agrees in principle that we
should do education but then they mean a
thousand different things with it but
the reality is the very best way to deal
with education is to focus on primary
education because that's where the
efforts are cheapest and the impacts are
the greatest so it's not about getting
you know tertiary and University
education it's about getting primary
education as you mentioned
eighty percent of 10 year old kids in
low and lower middle income countries
are functionally illiterate now they can
read they can read the individual words
but if you ask them and this is one of
those questions where you ask them read
this sentence that says Vijay has a red
hat blue shirt and yellow shoes what
color is the Hat
it's not hard it is red right but
unfortunately they can read the
individual words but they don't string
it together into a sentence so 80 fail
on this very very basic thing and of
course what that means is you're not
going to be very productive when you
become an adult we need to teach these
kids better the problem with all
education this is also to turn rich
countries but especially in poor
countries is that you have perhaps 50
kids they're all 12 year olds in the
same grade
but they're vastly different in
abilities some of these kids are far
beyond what the teacher is teaching some
of these kids have virtually no clue
what's going on so they are the board or
almost lost in there and what the
teacher should do is teach each one of
these kids at his or her own level but
of course you can do that if you have 50
but technology can so if you put each
one of these kids in front of a tablet
with educational software just for one
hour a day this educational software
will very quickly pick up on where
exactly this girl a boy is at and say
okay I'm gonna teach you from here on
and what happens is this educational
software can then teach you so well that
even though you still go to school for
seven hours that are still very boring
and you learn very little if you just do
this one hour a day the benefit of
course is that you can then share the
tablet with many others so it becomes
cheaper one hour a day for a year you
will learn as much as you normally would
have learned for three years so for
thirty one dollars for this uh this
thing and again this is very very well
tested assumes that some of this money
is going to go to corruption summer is
going to be misused because people are
incompetent some of these tablets are
going to get stolen you'll also need to
have solar panels to recharge them and
all this stuff all of this was included
in the in the costume we know these
things work for thirty one dollars you
can teach a kid three years of schooling
instead of one year and that means that
kid will become better and more
productive in its adult life and that
translates into about two thousand
dollars in higher incomes if we did this
for all the almost 600 million kids that
would generate an immense amount of
opportunity which is you know about 600
billion dollars uh a very large part of
the 1.1 trillion dollars you mentioned
before so fundamentally we can fix a
very simple problem it is not saying fix
all problems in education just like
we're not saying fix all problems in all
kinds of other ways we're saying here
are 12 very specific things that
actually are well documented to work
incredibly well at very low cost let's
do those first
um I seem to remember in earlier
iterations of the Copenhagen consensus
findings
um that there was an emphasis on
education for women or for girls
um you know has that been folded into
all of this or you know what happened to
that Focus has it been broadened so so
this this this has been brought about by
us asking The Economist now what is the
very best documented thing that we
believe would deliver a very high amount
of benefits uh and that was exactly as
we just talked about uh learning at the
right level is actually not just that
it's also one other thing structured
teacher planning so basically teach the
teachers to be better teachers because
often these teachers are just barely
better than their the kids that they're
teaching and they're not very good help
them give them structured teacher plans
and they'll also make them better
there's also a whole focus on getting
girls and a girls better educated but
remember that was very much a focus 10
20 years ago when girls were far behind
they just didn't get into school so a
very large focus in past was in simply
getting kids in school that makes sense
you know if if you don't have kids in
school you first want to get them in
school what we're learning now is
they're in school but they're just not
learning anything and so now the
movement is not any longer to get kids
in school and special girls into school
it's about teaching them stuff while
they're in there and that's where the
tablets come in I'm skipping around a
little bit but you put a a big premium
on agricultural r d you write that we
need a new Green Revolution what was the
Green Revolution and how do we make that
happen you know in the 21st century if
you think back in the 1960s a lot of
people were very very worried that we
wouldn't be able to feed the world uh
you know Paul Ehrlich was talking about
you know India's basket case we're just
going to have to let them you know flow
down hundreds of millions of people are
going to die that certainly seemed like
very big of him to be like Ah that's the
brakes yes well well in some sense if it
really was true then we probably should
triage I I don't I think he was probably
right given the time for uh the the
frame of mind back then
but we were right because there was
actually a really really simple solution
which was the Green Revolution it was
make every seed produce much more food
if you do that you still have all the
same Farmers they plant the same Acres
but much more food comes up that was
what the Green Revolution did but it did
it mostly for wheat rice and corn these
are this is great for us and for people
who live off of this but much especially
in Africa and some some places in
Southeast Asia live from other things
like sorcum and kasawa and all these
other things that we haven't even heard
of but need their own Green Revolution
we haven't been focused nearly as much
on this so when people talk about the
fact that they're still about it almost
a billion people that are going
malnourished the idea is to somehow to
say well we need to get more food to
them well it's really hard to and and
they do it in India for instance you buy
up lots of food and then you distribute
it to poor people first of all when you
buy up lots of food you're going to get
the worst food because they will sell it
to governments I I met with Gandhi who
was actually uh uh Distributing this uh
for it from Modi and she said try and
eat one of these cakes nobody wants it
right it's horrible thanks I'll starve
yeah I mean look you really have to
starve in order to to buy this but also
getting it distributed is really hard
and cost a lot of money it's much
smarter and that's what our Economist
told us instead of trying to distribute
a lot of extra food make agriculture
more efficient so invest a lot more in r
d That's much cheaper and what will
happen is you will both make the farmers
more productive that's great for them
because they'll actually make more money
but you'll also make prices on each of
these agricultural products lower which
is great for all the cities uh dwelling
people who will buy the food so it's
both better for producers better for
consumers and that means we get about
130 million fewer people starving it's
simply a fantastic investment you spend
very little and you again get a huge
benefit are you how confident are you
that okay we throw more money at r d and
it we'll figure it out so we're very
confident on that particular area
because we've been doing it for a very
long time and none of these assume that
we're going to find this amazing
breakthrough that we're giving it to a
lot of people and they never figured out
and then this one guy will get a big
breakthrough that's not how that works
everybody here's our Tinkers and get 1.5
percent better yields next year and then
somebody else comes along and Tinker a
little more and what we basically try to
do is instead of getting 1.5 if we get
1.7 growth then we're good over the the
next 50 years that's basically what we
investigate it doesn't give you as much
of the feel of oh I did something good
right now right that's the problem with
research and development it works in the
long run but we have very good knowledge
that if you invest this money well you
will get more of this now remember we're
not assuming that you invest it amazing
that you you know sort of with pure
foresight see the right people that you
invest in but you of course also have to
be careful that you don't end up just
investing in a lot of people who will
then buy you know four-wheel drives and
and and you know build a new fancy build
you have to be reasonably smart but if
you we know how to do that yes then you
can get these kinds of benefits um one
of the other recommendations is
increasing skilled migration you asked
to talk about increasing trade
um and I uh reason uh a reason audience
will you know be interested to know that
among the economists who've been a part
of the Copenhagen consensus is Vernon
Smith the Nobel Prize winner who we
interviewed earlier this year and
whatnot but talk about increasing
skilled migration
um this is something you know one of the
great uh you know kind of trends of the
past certainly the past I guess you
could say hundred years but certainly
the past 30 or 40 years has been the
relatively free flow of people from
country to Country which is really kind
of amazing in a historical context but
it seems now that a lot of people are
kind of like hey you know what we need
to be building more walls uh not opening
more doors so how do you what's the
benefit of increased skilled migration
yes so we both argue I should say for
free trade and for uh for for more skill
migration we're basically pointing out
there's a huge economic benefit but we
also recognize that especially in the uh
transfer of people there's a significant
political issue uh and so I go through
you know sort of economists will tell
you that they're a trillion dollar bills
lying on the floor uh that if you just
open the world uh you know pretty much
all the world's poor will go to rich
countries and they'll become much more
productive and then we'll all be much
better off there is a little hiccup in
the sense that we have about you know
600 million people in the rich world
that are in working age and we're
talking about a transfer of 2.4 billion
people coming into the the rich world
that's not going to go off without a
hitch that will have enormous
consequences of course especially for
the people who are already in the rich
world who will see their wages often
drop now overall it means that more
people will become much more productive
so it is true that there are trillion
dollar bills lying on the floor but it
has huge political implications which is
why a lot of people are against it what
we're trying to say is skilled migration
has the opportunity of doing something
that you can actually get people on
board with we're not saying open up
orders for skill trade we're saying have
10 more
skilled migration than what you already
have so countries that are very
comfortable like Canada with my
migration they will take in 10 of them
rather large number countries that are
very skeptical would take in 10 of a
very low number the benefit is if you
for instance get doctors or stem workers
from poor countries to rich countries
they become much much more productive
they have the education but they can now
deliver much higher productivity that's
where the big benefit comes from and of
course what that means is that that
doctor will now be part of a much richer
World which means that he or she how
does that that in that scenario how does
the money or the wealth go back to the
poor country or is it a brain drain so
yes so so it the main thing that I'm
thinking mostly of England where all
doctors will leave England the minute
that they can oh absolutely so look the
main benefit comes to the people who
actually move right and remember
otherwise they would have stayed a poor
now they get to actually be better off
so that's the big benefit but it's
reasonable to talk about what what about
the brain brain well we estimate that
net it'll also be a benefit for the uh
uh uh the transfer country so for the uh
for the country that delivers the doctor
both because they get remittances we
know that that happens all through life
but also those remittances lead to more
education for the people in that country
because they know that they now have
that stable uh uh uh uh money flow from
remittances which means that they get
better educated so you actually end up
with higher education but it is not a
great deal for a descending country it
is mostly a great deal for the
individuals that we move
um I want to talk about this because it
this is the one that struck me as uh
kind of most new to me and and
interesting you talk about e procurement
or electronic electric procurement what
is that and why how did that make the
list it is a really really sort of
surprising thing most people have never
heard of it but think about it the
biggest consumer of almost everything in
the world is typically the state because
they buy everything from you know
Post-it notes to roads but you know
fundamentally most of this money is an
infrastructure and this is typically
incredibly corrupt uh so we worked with
Bangladesh for instance uh and they have
this Old English system that whenever
you know the government needs something
new built they'll put out in this
obscure paper that you can we we want
this bridge and and please hand in your
sealed envelope with your bid in this
office but of course the reality is you
already have the Glo local Elite have
already decided you're going to get that
job and so they put up goons outside the
office so you literally physically can't
get in with your envelope this is how
you keep having too high costs for for
governments and you typically also get
low uh uh quality in e-procurement is
very basically there's more to it but
very basically that you just put this
project on eBay you just ask people to
say here's what we'd like we like this
bridge then you type in everybody can
see it now you don't have to go to this
obscure paper it becomes much harder to
put these goons up you can still do it
but it's harder to do so what you
basically avoid is a lot of corruption
and you get higher quality because more
people will bid you also typically get a
cheaper sorry faster so you basically
get a lot of benefits in Bangladesh
again we showed that this means on
average that your prices will go down by
6.75 if you look across a wide range of
countries we also did this particularly
in Bangladesh but you know you get
things somewhat cheaper it's probably
very much the uh the corruption that you
avoid but the benefit of course means
that for Bangladesh it means they have
700 million dollars each and every year
that they can now use in things that'll
actually help the pop population instead
of going into coffers of people who are
corrupt this is great and the Finance
Minister loved it in Bangladesh but of
course he also knows that the people a
couple of levels below will be really
really annoyed because that's you know
part of their income so there's real
cost to this you need to have political
push but actually it turns out for very
little money so we estimate there's
still about 70 countries in the world
that haven't implemented e-programming
most rich countries have U.S absolutely
uh but you can do it even more you can
do it better but mostly these 70
countries should do it it'll cost about
sorry 76 million dollars so it's the
only thing that's not billions of
dollars it's it's super super cheap and
what it'll deliver is benefits worth
about 10 billion dollars so every dollar
spent will do 137 sorry 135 dollars
worth of good that's just a fantastic
thing we should just do it it's also it
seems related to the land tenure
security at least tenuously in terms of
When Things become more transparent who
owns things and they have a legitimate
right to it you just lower transaction
costs tremendously yes and and you know
it's it's a it's a question of having
secured and just knowing that you own
stuff that has a huge you know different
both you can use as a collateral but
also just your own life you can actually
you know relax and say this is mine uh
it has a huge uh difference in in how
countries and how effective economies
are and again we showed that land tenure
will have significant cost because you
actually need to have cadastral surveys
and you need to have better uh Court uh
uh resolution all these things but the
benefits will vastly outweigh the costs
you know this is all so compelling when
I read it when I've been reading the
various iterations over there I'm like
of course of course of course what about
the political economy you've mentioned
you know kind of there's a lot of people
invested in the system as it is who are
going to fight like cats and dogs to
keep any of any kind of Reform from
coming how do you move it forward as a
actual political program that has a
chance of being implemented so I think
the biggest problem that we really face
is that everybody wants to feel like
we're doing everything remember if you
know Americans do this a lot it's a
little foreign for European Spain but
come Christmas you'll sit and write out
checks to you know your uh this kennel
or this uh this drug shelter or whatever
it is and and the point is you know any
Economist that look at that would say
but one of these things is the best you
should just send all the money you know
the whole two thousand dollars to that
thing but no you write out you know 10
checks and the reason is because it
feels like you've done 10 times as much
good right it feels like you've you've
been part of solving 10 problems instead
of one so the feeling I think is very
Universal you want to do a lot of good
things that's really why we have the
sustainable development goals that just
basically promise everything instead we
should do the smartest stuff first that
is hard because it means saying no to a
lot of things I have that wonderful
quote by Steve Jobs when they ask them
what are you most proud of you know what
what is it we should really focus on he
said it's not about saying yes to stuff
it's about saying no I'm so proud of all
the things I've said no to you have to
say no to a lot of things in order to
say yes to the few things that really
matter so we should do this so so your
question sorry no no no I I mean I that
that logic makes a lot of sense and then
it's a question of who is going to be
saying yes or no is it something that
gets forced through the U.N and they
develop you know something or is it
individual countries that say you know
what we are are going to pursue this and
we're you know we're gonna we're gonna
Focus uh you know Bangladesh we're going
to focus on e-procurement or something
like that
I think I I see myself as an
intellectual I put forward an argument
for 12 things that would be incredibly
good I think what it really does is it
makes it a little more likely in every
uh in the usaid OR in all these
different development agencies around
the world in negotiations between people
if you're a philanthropist it becomes a
little more likely that people are going
to pick one of those 12 things they're
not going to do all 12 of them that's
fine but they're going to pick one of
those because oh I read this book and
actually says this is incredibly
efficient so it pushes a little bit us
more to spending money where it's really
efficient and a little less on all the
other things I would love as an
economist I would love
for us to just do smart stuff but I also
recognize this as a real world so we
have a saying in our organization it's
not about getting it right it's about
getting it slightly less wrong now if we
can help move the world a little bit
towards funding more of the 12 and a
little less of all the other stuff we've
won is there any indication that's
happening I think there is a little bit
but look
um it's very very hard to tell when
we've done this in individual countries
for instance for Bangladesh they
actually did a procurement not just
because we said it but you know this is
part of the movement towards that I
think they did a few other things really
well in in Malawi where we work they
actually did do uh and and they're right
now doing uh tablets for kids in primary
school they're trying to get this out
across the entire country uh partly
because of the calculations that we've
done so I think we help giving good
ideas but again the point here is that
it has to be taken up by individual
philanthropists and by governments and
again remember usaid is trying to do a
thousand things and they're also very
Bound by a lot of uh Congress people who
put different restrictions on them in
all kinds of ways and likewise
philanthropies are always you know they
start out we want to you know save the
world but they often end up in places
that just look good on TV and I just
want to make sure that people focus a
little bit more on the actual
Effectiveness I think we we help push
people to be a little smarter but no
this is not what's going to save the
whole world you know we've talked a
little bit about the sustainable
development goals from 2015 that you
know were kind of the worst version of a
un thumb sucker kind of uh activity in
the book you talk about the Millennium
development goals and how they were
successful can you remind us of what the
Millennium development goals were and
why were they successful in a way that
the sdgs are not going to be yeah so the
millennium development goals were really
developed by uh Kofi Annan and a few
other guys they were all guys in a back
room in the UN in around 2000 so they
came up with this very very short list
of things so let's stop uh uh poverty
and hunger let's get all kids in school
go clean drinking water and sanitation
stop moms from dying stop kids from
dying that was that
so we've made a very very short list
that's actually a little longer but
everybody decided to ignore it but you
know mostly we just had these eight
smart things and when you set out eight
things and it was a new millennium and
we said we should do something let's do
these things remember not all of these
things happen because the UN said it yes
we got a lot more people out of poverty
but that was mostly because China got
rich uh but we did actually spend a lot
more money on making sure the kids
didn't die uh for instance through
vaccinations we know vaccinations like
uh against measles it's just a good idea
and back then almost no kids were
vaccinated after that about 80 were
vaccinated still not enough but much
much better and it saved 800
000 lives how amazing is that and if you
add all of this up we actually went from
in 1990 about 12 million kids died each
year before their fifth birthday in 2015
when the Millennium development goals
were done only and I put that inverted
commas only six million kids died now
that's still six million too many but
because the cohorts were about the same
that's actually six million P kids that
don't die and that's on a tremendous
achievement we didn't actually meet the
target so we're a little too unrealistic
but we did a lot of good and so if you
focus on a few smart things and get
people's attention you can actually do
something you can't do it about
everything and certainly there were not
all equally smart but we did manage to
do a lot of good because we focused with
the sdgs we said let's do everything for
everyone and then of course you don't
have any Focus you don't get any uh uh
acceleration there's been no measurable
pickup people have not gotten more
excited of anything that jigsaw in a
little wow that's a lot of things we
promised so focus on a few things and
say these are the best things you can do
that's what I try to do in the book and
basically if we can get people to say I
want to be part of one of those all
things that's the way you make big
difference how um you know is there also
a sense that the you know or let me
start over
um in in the United States and certainly
among kind of classical liberals
Libertarians I think that's probably
true of uh of Europe as well the UN is
in an increasingly you know terrible uh
reputation right I mean it just it's it
never really seems to get things done
Etc like that can you talk a little bit
about you know the massive decline in
global poverty uh both extreme poverty
and just regular poverty
um you know has really uh you know been
spectacular and it was really unexpected
at the level and right it was how much
of the decline in global poverty was due
to these larger issues like you were
talking about you know a kind of free
trade or globalization uh China
um you know starting to turn more to a
market economy and how much or you know
how can we say you know the un's adopt
opting certain ideas or pushing certain
ideas was responsible for X percentage
of that or is it all part of the same
kind of movement towards it no sorry I
don't think anyone really believe that
the poverty had anything to do with you
know these Grand promises from the U.N
from any other place it comes from
Economic Development uh and and you know
no no leader in the world is going to
say no I don't want to do you know
Economic Development and then the UN
says we well you should oh okay then
I'll do it that's not how that works you
want to have more people in jobs you
want to get your nation richer these are
things that you don't actually need to
promise what you do need to promise
perhaps much more focused is to make
sure that women don't die in childbirth
because that's a that's a marginalized
group of uh you know if if you look at
hospitals they're often run by men uh
they're often about old people that are
deceased they typically the same sort of
demographic as the politicians uh
whereas you know women coming in to give
birth that's not so exciting so they're
underfunded but that's one of the places
where we can make sure that both women
survive much more and their kids which
are all of our kids survive much more at
very low cost so again this is one of
the places where you can actually make a
difference by focusing people's
attention likewise with education
everybody will say that you should do
education but then when you come down to
it for a lot of people it's more about
well actually I'd like to have free
education college education for my kids
which you know ends up being a subsidy
to rich people's kids because those are
the ones who go to college what you need
to focus on but that's much more boring
is to get it right in price memory
education and so you can focus people's
attention more with the sort of sort of
these promises but what you have to make
sure is you don't promise everything uh
you have to promise a few really smart
things and that's what we're trying to
say look the UN should have done their
job better they didn't and I I
understand why you know when I went
around talked to a lot of the UN
ambassadors individually and talk to
them about why they should pick really
smart stuff and they're all like this is
really interesting but actually
you know the Brazilian Ambassador would
tell me but you know my job is not to
get the best targets for the world my
job is to get Brazil's Five Points in
there and you know the Norwegian
ambassador to get Norway's Four Points
in there that's how we ended up with a
list of everything yeah
uh let's talk about climate change and
the discourse related to it uh uh you
know it's almost 25 years ago right you
made a name for yourself I think you
really emerged on the on the world stage
um as uh the skeptical environmentalist
which was the title of one of your first
books or your first big book what made
you skeptical skeptical about
environmentalists policy discussions
back then
so I was an old Greenpeace or not in the
sense I was out in the rubber boat but
you know I had the poster and the
backpack and the badge and I you know I
had all those sorts of uh middle class
worried uh uh and you were you grew up
in sweet uh in Denmark yeah
uh and and yeah certainly from here uh
but yeah
um fundamentally I was very worried I
thought the world was coming off yeah
off the wheels were coming off the uh
the cart
that's a bad metaphor the way I just
formulate I I thought things were going
wrong and we needed to do better uh and
I thought you know the environmentalist
was telling a very important Story the
world is getting worse and worse we need
to do a lot of stuff to do I realized
that's not what the data mostly tells us
actually as we become richer we have and
most important areas both of environment
and also non-environment fixed a lot of
problems remember air pollution used to
be terrible in most rich countries it
was terrible in London around 1900 since
then air pollution has come down
dramatically for many reasons partly
because air pollution is an indication
that you're producing inefficiently so
you can actually do better by by
reducing pollution but also as you get
richer it's also just simply you know
I'm I'm richer I'd like to cough a
little less so let's do more regulation
and make sure that we actually get
cleaner air we have gotten incredibly
clean air we probably have cleaner air
today in most rich countries than we've
had for last at least four or five
hundred years this is a tremendous
achievement we have the same thing with
water and many other places now not
everything is fine you know climate
change for instance is one of those
problems that are actually getting worse
it is important to say that there are
still environmental problems but it's
incredibly important to recognize we
have solved many more problems and we
have cost new ones we're not sort of a
plague on the on on the planet and of
course also if this scare story at the
end is nigh is not correct it's probably
also important to not let us be scared
into spending money but actually keep
asking what is Smart spending and that's
what I did on the on the climate and in
in General on the environmental front
and I think that
pissed off a lot of people because a lot
of environmental movement is basically a
predicated on the idea I'm going to
scare you witless and then I'm going to
ask for all your money and then we're
going to fix the problem well that's not
how you should fix problems should you
actually get a sense of how big of a
problem is it what can we do what it'll
cost what are the Alternatives so
certainly in developed countries air
quality is better I think in every city
in America the air quality is better now
than it was 30 years ago or 40 years ago
and you know for Libertarians part of
that you know we have to work through it
that it's the result of Regulation it's
a result of laws but
um you know one one argument is that
well we've taken you know we've just
shoved all of our pollution onto the
developing world and when you look at
emerging economies like China in
particular the air quality there is
getting worse and worse is that an
accurate read or what is that missing so
so there's definitely a sense in which
we've pushed some pollution but remember
for instance you can't push
Transportation pollution on other
countries because you need the
transportation here and what we've done
is also dramatically reduced air
pollution from Transportation so we
really have made our world cleaner but
remember for poor countries typically
you'll do exactly the same thing as what
America and the UK did back in the early
part of industrialization said hey if I
can get rich I'm willing to cough more
that's how it works that you're willing
to trade off if you can get better off
and you know send your kids to college
and have a lot of other benefits you're
willing to also accept more pollution
certainly in the short run that's what
they've done in in in poor countries and
certainly Beijing and and uh China for a
long term a long time was getting worse
and worse air pollution levels now
you've actually seen this turn in many
of the richest uh uh developing uh sorry
developing countries so you know Chile
for instance I have I've already 20 or
30 years ago seen starting declining
levels of air pollution China has
probably just broken this level again
but in India and other places where
you're much poorer you're still seeing
air pollution levels going up most of
this is a very conscious choice of
saying we'd like to get richer and part
of the way we get richer is by allowing
more air pollution it's only once you
get sufficiently rich you say now I'd
like to pay for Less air is there any
reason to be worried about
um you know well you know saying to the
developing World we're sorry we can't
allow you to do that because the total
amount of pollution is going to create a
you know a hockey stick or a ratchet
effect where the planet just starts
dying
um you know it is that a legitimate
argument or is that something that you
don't think is supported by it it has
some Merit but it also has a lot of
problems attached with it so remember
air pollution is really a local issue uh
or at best a a regional issue so it
makes sense to say look what China wants
of its air pollution is mostly a problem
for China they can decide that level for
themselves but the Crux here is that's
not true for global warming because
global warming is really comes from
emitting CO2 and no matter where you
emit CO2 it has the same Global Effect
just over a couple years or so so this
is really a global issue it doesn't help
that the U.S Cuts its emissions if it
just means they're transferred over to
China or elsewhere so you really have to
get everybody on board now remember
nobody emits CO2 because they you know
think it's funner they want to know Al
Gore they do this because it's a side
effect of using power which is one of
the most advantageous things in in the
world remember a couple you know
Generations ago we were basically all
struggling just to get through life most
most of us working on farms being
incredibly poor with our own muscles is
the only thing that we could work with
now we have all this energy mostly
fossil fuel energy that basically
provides servants uh you and I and most
rich people have servants equivalent to
somewhere between 100 and 200 people
working 24 7 for you that's the Roomba
you have the uh you know the horses in
your car and all these other things that
provide all these amazing benefits that
we have the point here is to say there
is a real problem from climate change
but there is also a real benefit to all
of these
very tangible things when you go out and
tell new countries no I'm sorry I I know
we got rich with fossil fuels and that
was really cool for us but you can't do
it you can't uh develop this way you
have to use solar and wind now if Solon
wind was so great that they're actually
cheaper which of course a lot of people
will claim
then it might make sense but then you
wouldn't have to tell the people because
they would just do it because it was
cheaper but of course that's not
actually true that's why we have to
subsidize them here that's why we have
to push him on to poor people
fundamentally solar and wind is cheaper
maybe when the sun is shining and the
wind is blowing but when it's not it's
infinitely expensive and that's why most
people just have it as a little Boutique
add-on in reality most countries will
only get rich if they have lots of power
cheaply available and available 24 7.
and that will typically right now mostly
be fossil fuel so when we're telling
countries I'm sorry you can't have that
we are in effect telling you will have
to do with less growth in some sense
you'll have to get used to be important
that's a terrible from your perspective
what's the best framework then because
if this is you know a climate Commons
it's a global issue what's the framework
um to kind of get people to coordinate
in a way that doesn't get you know give
rise to the worst case scenario yeah so
there's two things you have to recognize
in this one is the economically
effective solution is a carbon tax any
Economist would say you should have a
tax that equals the disbenefit of
emitting CO2 and that means you've now
internalized it and then we should shut
up about it if you get that right in the
system the system will solve itself
that's what the market mechanism does
so first of all this has to be about how
big of a problem is climate change
because if climate change right now a
lot of people will tell you it's an
existential crisis as the end of the
world then of course you have to do
everything and the kitchen sink to fix
this problem but that's not what the U.N
climate panel tells us what it tells us
is it's a problem it's not the end of
the world and that's why you can
actually fix it with a carbon tax
but you have to recognize this will
always ever only be a smaller part of
the actual solution you'll get a little
reduction in CO2 emissions but that's
about it the only way you're going to
solve this is through Innovation that's
how we solved all other problems you
don't solve problems by telling people
I'm sorry could you be a little colder a
little more uncomfortable a little
poorer uh but you know use these things
that are nicer for the world that just
doesn't work in general and certainly a
lot in the long run and for all
countries the way you solve this is by
making sure that green energy is
actually cheaper and more effective look
at what happened with fracking in the
U.S you had a situation where you used a
lot of coal because that was by far the
cheapest way to generate uh uh
electricity unfortunately coal is also
the biggest polluter of CO2 what came
along was you basically had this new
technology that made fracking that made
gas much cheaper gas produces about half
as much CO2 as coal so suddenly you had
a situation where something that was
greener was also cheaper everyone
switched you had a dramatic reduction in
the production of now in the U.S and you
know Joe Biden has banned fracking on
federal lands environmentalists I was
just looking at this the other day we
ran an article 10 years ago
environmentalists used to be for
fracking before they were against it no
the green movement doesn't like fracking
anymore no and and look there's some
sense to this because what they say is
also we need to move you know we move
from a high fossil fuel to a medium
fossil fuel if you will to gas but
eventually we need to move to zero
emissions and that makes sense that then
you know you can't just keep on doing
fracking but you also got to be
realistic most of the world is going to
be using more and more fossil fuels for
the foreseeable future and so what you
want to do is to make sure that China
goes from coal to gas not to say none no
you can't use either and then of course
just end up having trying to keep on
using coal so the reality here is if you
live in the real world you should do a
better rather than a poor option instead
of saying no it all has to be uh you
know Pure or nothing
um you know you you said that um you
know what we need to do is to tax carbon
you know at the level of its disbenefit
you make that sound like that's an easy
calculation how political ultimately is
that or how subjective is that to
actually price out the cost you know the
the negative effects of carbon yeah
that's that's hard uh but I think the
main problem here is you have to be
honest that was the value of the present
versus the future or what the economists
know is the discount rate uh if the
president is very important compared to
the Future climate change is just not a
very big issue if the far a future is
incredibly important in the present
honestly not all that important to you
then climate is a big issue that's
really what drives the the correct uh
CO2 price so not surprisingly most
people who argue for we should do a lot
for climate will say well the future is
much more important than the present but
remember this may be true for rich
well-off people but it's certainly not
true for most people in the world
because honestly they worry about the
fact that their kids might die from
infectious disease diseases tonight and
so worrying about what the temperature
is in 100 years is a very very big
luxury so can I ask this kind of goes
back to our earlier conversation how do
you get
um you know what how do you get the
people who need to be at the table there
to say okay here's the framework and
we're actually going to do it I remember
you writing about the Paris Accords
where you know when those are being torn
up by I guess by uh Donald Trump you
pointed out that even if they had
succeeded they would have had a
virtually negligible effect on the you
know temperature change so
um you know what's the political economy
of of a global carbon tax well
fundamentally it's not going to happen
but also even if you manage to do this
it would only have a smaller impact on
the temperature that's of course why I
keep saying if you actually want to do
something about climate it all comes
down to Innovation so we actually did a
cost benefit analysis just like the one
we talked about just for climate so not
saying you know maybe you should spend
your money on tuberculosis but if you
just care about climate what's the
smartest thing the long run smartest
thing is to invest in Innovation just
like we talked about with agriculture
the only way you're going to solve this
is by making sure that future green
energy is so cheap that everybody wants
to buy it all right we'll leave it there
Bjorn lomborg thanks for talking to
reason thank you
foreign